speaking of weather southwest airlines
says weather was a factor in major
travel disruptions across the country
over the weekend the airline canceled
more than 1800 flights starting on
friday that's far more than any other
carrier and it's raising big questions
for southwest arrow barnett is following
this arrow good morning
hey there good morning nate look people
are still feeling the pain right now
some southwest passengers won't make it
to their weekend destination until
tuesday because of the mass
cancellations and this ripple effect but
sources tell cbs news all of this is at
least partly related to the airline's
position on following the federal
vaccine mandate which some southwest
pilots disagree with
it's not a great end to a good vacation
long lines snaked around airport
terminals as passengers rushed to
re-book unexpectedly cancelled flights
on a busy holiday weekend we've been on
the phone
i think we're on hold for like three and
a half hours now and then we're probably
two hours into waiting in line and
probably another hour till we get there
southwest says air traffic control and
weather related challenges caused
cancellations of nearly 2 000 flights
but the faa responded sunday saying its
staffing shortages ended friday and that
airlines are having challenges due to
aircraft and crews being out of place
industry expert henry hardevelt what
really bothers me is southwest is trying
to blame the faa air traffic control
systems it's like saying the dog ate my
homework
southwest is clashing with its pilots
union over the federal vaccine mandate
swapper filed a lawsuit on friday but
denies it organized a so-called sick out
and says there were many operational
difficulties due to management's poor
planning southwest says it's operating
at lower staff levels than it did
pre-pandemic and cannot recover quickly
still sources tell cbs news a staffing
shortage this weekend was a factor in
why so many southwest flights were cut
what is the connection between the union
lawsuit we saw filed on friday and these
cancellations officially there's no
connection unofficially what i've heard
is there are some rogue pilots who are
anti-vaccine
folks they are not showing up for work
is this disruption a glimpse of what's
to come southwest's absolute meltdown
doesn't bode well for thanksgiving or
for christmas
now internally southwest is apologizing
to some of its staff who couldn't find
hotel rooms and accommodations which
only made the situation worse but
consider this the airline vaccine
mandate enforced by the federal
government takes hold december 8th and
the southwest pilots union gale does
intend to demonstrate for better terms
also in the month of december
yeah let's hope they work that out errol
because you know thanksgiving and
christmas as you point out are coming
thanks a lot